hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
welt heute gibt es endlich mal wieder
ein salat rezept von mir den ganzen
sommer über habe ich ja keine salat
rezepte veröffentlicht der erste und
letzte glaube ich war sogar der bus hat
letztes jahr
und heute soll es ein ganz schneller und
ganz leckere salate egal wo ich den
salat nachfragen immer alle leute nach
dem rezept dabei ist es wirklich ein
ganz einfaches salat ihr braucht nur
ganz wenige zutaten und er ist wirklich
sehr schnell gemacht ich werde heute
eine sehr große menge zu bereiten da wir
heute ein großes grillfest haben aber
ihr könnt euch hat die mengen einfach
etwas runter rechnen und eben den
gesprächen so bereiten
ich habe jetzt hier karotten ich mache
heute eine ganz große menge deswegen
habe ich fast 1700 gramm karotten
ich habe jetzt bereits geschält und es
ist auch dass geschälte gewicht und die
müssen jetzt noch fein geraspelt werden
ich mach das ganz gerne wenn die in
studien geschnitten werden also keine
stifte aber ich werde jetzt heult meine
gemüse schneider benutzen und falsches
serie von kitchen elster habe ich diese
gemüse schneidet rommel drin und die ich
relativ ein also die schneidet die
karotten so fein und ich werde jetzt
einfach die karotten klein machen
das ist so viel karotten und die werden
jetzt in der pfanne ganz kurz angebraten
ihnen etwas olivenöl
ich musste sitzt auf zwei portionen
machen weil es eben so eine große menge
ist und ihr müsst ihr jetzt dann
aufpassen dass er sie eben nicht durch
gab sondern dass er einfach kurz
angebraten werden und dann kommen sie
auch sofort wieder raus der auch schon
wie es anfängt zu knistern und sogar und
jetzt lastet es einfach immer so ein
paar sekunden und rührt dann durch wie
gesagt damit sie eben noch schön knackig
bleiben wenn die karotten dann so 23
minuten in der pfanne waren kenntnisse
herausnehmen
wie gesagt soll sie ja noch ganz kurzer
abgekommen
die karotten lasse jetzt einfach
vollständig abkühlen und danach geht es
dann mit dem joghurt weiter für den
joghurt braucht ihr jetzt etwas pfeffer
salz und knoblauchzehen auf die menge
nämlich jetzt man halt einen teelöffel
pfeffer etwa zwei teelöffel sahen 4
knoblauchzehen und ein joghurt benutze
ich immer diesem gas wie joghurt dessen
stichfeste joghurt er hat zehn prozent
fett den türkischen klub zu kaufen
die knoblauchzehen habe ich jetzt schon
mal gehabt und in der große schüssel
gegeben den joghurt gebe ich jetzt
komplett verheilt ist ein kilo weizen
leicht auf der für die menge ausreicht
ich sehe mich da wie gesagt so etwas
zwei teelöffel salz heim lebt stand im
pfeffer rein und verrührt es einfach
schön ins schwitzen kommen
da die karotten mit rein und dann wird
es ganz einfach mit führt ein bisschen
weniger gut deswegen gebe ich noch mal
600 gramm mit dazu ich mag es gern wenn
joghurt und karotten im verhältnis eins
zu eins in das heißt ich hatte fast über
1600 karotten und habe jetzt auch 1600
aber da könnte einfach nach geschmack
mehr oder weniger nehmen wird möchte
einfach nur marc schmecken mit salz
pfeffer und knoblauch und eben nach
geschmack und einfach so lange in den
kühlschrank stellen
bis ihr den salat braucht den rat könnt
ihr auch ganz gut vorbereiten
ich mag es oft so dass ich in einen tag
vorher mache in den kühlschrank stellen
und wenn ich ihn brauche nämlich in ein
fach mit eurer stelle ihn einfach raus
ich hoffe das rezept gefällt euch in die
meldet es nachmachen jetzt wünsche ich
euch viel spaß dabei wünsche euch noch
einen schönen tag und bis bald